Wendell Melton will be serving 28 years
to life for murdering his teen son it's
been five years since that tragedy and
now the victim's mom says she's been
preparing for this day ever since she
lost her son it was Wendell Melton's
last chance to say anything before he
was sentenced
prosecutors say on November 2nd 2017
Melton had a gun on him when he went to
confront his son fourteen-year-old
Giovanni at an apartment where he lived
alone and passed reports police say the
two started to argue when Giovanni was
shot this coward shot his own unarmed 14
year old child in the chest the murderer
was not a bank robber a drug addict or a
thug it was Giovanni's own biological
father since Giovanni's murder his mom
Veronica Melton has claimed her son was
murdered by his dad because he was gay
my son Giovanni being gay
do not cost in this market Melton's
attorney Joseph Reef claiming his client
should be able to live some of his years
outside of prison wide range of people
love Mr Mountain dearly
that it means everything in the world to
them that there is hope for him my son
will never come home to his family
neither should Wendell outside the
courtroom Giovanni's mom told us how she
felt about the sentencing can you
finally find some closure after today
I can find closure because I know that
now this man will be behind bars there
is possibility that Wendell Melton will
be eligible for parole after serving 28
years but Giovanni's mom says she wants
to be at that parole hearing to make
sure her son's murderer never sees life
outside of prison reporting from
downtown Las Vegas Victoria Saha 8 News
Now